[Music]
and one from aj he submitted this let's
pray first
yes father in heaven as we enter the
second phase grant us more wisdom and
insight and light in jesus name we pray
amen amen okay so this question comes
from aj sees i also had a question
pastor skeet had mentioned in his sermon
that we must not cook on the sabbath i
love cooking especially cooking for
others i used to cook on sabbath
afternoons and then go to members of our
church of our church's homes
uh to drop it off some of them are
seniors and live on their own it was
such a blessing however after hearing
the sermon i stopped
and
all right let me just continue i stopped
i'm working every day from 7 30 to 9 30
often 12 to 14 hours every day except
sabbath i tried to cook on sundays for
others but then ended up having no time
left for family chores and family and
back to work monday another pastor who
knows my schedule said what i was doing
for others um
and it was good who knows
who knows my schedule and and what i was
doing for others said it was good i was
doing good on the sabbath could you
please help me with this or ask pastor
skeet this question
on zoom with him i love studying his
word and want to do things that please
well studying his word that's god's word
and want to do things that please him
thank you
anything god asks you to do
he makes a way for you to do it
if god tells us and he tells us next to
16 we shouldn't cook on the sabbath day
we shouldn't do it
if this person feels that this is a
noble work and god makes an exception
the person ought to say to god father
make a way for me to provide this
service without violating your holy
commandment once you make an exception
of the commandment one or two or three
or four you've got to make it to seven
eight and nine
there are no exceptions when it comes to
obeying god you cannot make exceptions
for obedience because disobedience is
sin we're not to cook on the sabbath i'm
not saying we're harsh and we're made of
steel and we don't bend i'm simply
saying we choose to honor god above
everything else when christ had died he
died the ladies wanted to anoint his
body this is the body of the creator the
body of their savior they refused to do
it they saw where he was bearing they
went home and kept the sabbath according
to the commandment when the sabbath was
over then they came to a point like the
body of jesus let me say it again they
refused to anoint the body of jesus
christ who was the one who said let
there be light who is the one who said i
am the resurrection and the life who is
the one who said i am my father are one
they would not anoint that body why
because it was the south
when god sees you determined to obey him
he will open the way for you to do what
it is you want to do so my counsel is do
everything to honor god
this may sound harsh above the hungry
even though god cares about the hungry
put god for and god will open the way
for you to provide that service which is
an excellent service by the way but
seven after this yes the bible tells us
all right makes it clear we should not
cook on sabbath it is okay to warm it
but we should not cook on sabbath plain
and simple cook on friday cook on
thursday put in the refrigerator you
have no refrigerator leave it outside if
god kept it to the days of the
israelites he will keep it today because
he has not changed
but we must do everything
to honor god first the bible says he
that lovely father and mother more than
me is not worthy of me luke 10 37 we
must love god first put him first
yes this may sound harsh again we must
put him above the poor the whomever will
never put in first
even though christ was found among them
we must put god first then god will show
us how to serve the poor how to serve
the homeless how to serve the unemployed
without offending him
always look for a way to obey god always
look for way there has to be a way
amen amen thank you oleski
you